Rather than having money sit in your bank account, it's a good idea to have it work for you by investing.
Even small amounts like 20 dollars, for example, can be put into a DRP, a dividend investment plan.
This way, you buy stock directly from companies and avoid brokers and their commissions.
If you have a few hundred dollars to spare, you could look at an index fund.
You can buy index funds straight from mutual fund companies with no commissions.
This is a good and inexpensive way to start a widely diversified portfolio.
If you have 500 dollars, you may want to consider a discount brokerage account...
...and choose an account option that is ideal for you.
The important thing is that you keep your investment costs...
...and broker fees to less than 2% of the transaction amount.